Day:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this
morning's session.
My name is David.
Raub:
I'm Susannah.
Day: We're both engineers
working on the Maps API
in the Sydney office,
and today we're going
to be talking to you
about speedy maps.
So in particular, we're
really going to be emphasizing
how you can make your website
itself as quick as possible,
and then once your website
is quick,
how you can get
the map on that page
to be super fast as well.
Raub: So over the years
at Google,
we've learned
a number of things,
one of the most important being
that fast is better than slow.
And this applies directly
to loading web pages fast
and making them fast
once your users arrive
at the web page.
Why is this important?
The longer it takes
your web page to load,
the more likely your user is
to go and find
what they're looking for
somewhere else.
And it's important that once
they arrive at your website,
that it performs well
and interacts smoothly
and seamlessly for them,
so that they forget
that they're in this
two-dimensional web browser
with this--what could be
static content
and instead immerse them
in the world
that you're
trying to deliver.
So today, we'll talk about
how to make both of these parts
of your page faster.
On the Maps API Team, we work
really hard to do our part
to make sure that what we're
delivering to you is fast,
but it's important that you
also use these principles
to make your page
and your map fast.
So we'll talk about the--
when you load resources,
how to optimize them
and make the resource loading
as efficient as possible.
We'll also talk about
some of the difficulties
of developing
in the browser
and how you can work
with and around it.
Then we'll talk about how
to move some of the hard work
out of the client and onto
your servers and our servers.
And we'll cover some of
the tools and technologies
that exist in the browser
to help you make these pages
as fast as possible.
So here we see a chart
that shows the amount of time
it took to load various size
JavaScript files.
Now, loading resources
is a combination of things.
It takes time to do a DNS lookup
to make a return trip
to the server to actually
fetch the data
and then to parse the data
and to execute it
in the browser.
Now, these numbers
are pretty general.
Because there are these
different components to loading,
and every browser
is a little different,
and every device is different,
there's no hard and fast rule
as to how long it takes
to load a particular resource.
Plus, that parsing and executing
can vary a lot
by the complexity
of the resource loaded.
But what we do know is
that the bigger the file is,
the longer it takes.
This chart is just emphasizing
that point.
Bigger files,
longer time.
Now, there are many ways
to reduce the size of the files
that you download, but
the really core principle here
is to load only the necessary
resources at any given time--
that because it takes time
to load each resource
and each big resource,
load as little as possible.
We do this in the Maps API
by only loading up front
what you need to
create your map,
and we wait to load the rest
of the components later,
until they're actually
required.
Day: So one of the most
powerful ways
you can reduce one of the heavy
components of your page,
the JavaScript,
is to send it through
a compiler or a minifier.
So the job of a minifier
is basically to do
some simple manipulation
of your JavaScript files.
For example, it will
strip out comments.
It will collapse white space,
so it's all normalized.
And it can also do some
simple variable renaming,
particularly the parameters
of functions.
JavaScript compilation
really takes it that next step,
because it can understand
the semantics of what
your JavaScript is trying to do.
And so it can do
much more aggressive
optimizations,
like renaming variables
that look like they're global,
but only your program
is using them.
And even doing things
like in-lining functions
completely away.
So in the top code
sample there,
I've got a bit
of a toy piece of code
which calculates
the nth Fibonacci number.
And as you can see,
I haven't taken any care
making that small.
There's big
variable names.
I've even made a bit
of a silly function,
just to add two numbers
together,
so you can see
it's a big waste of space.
Now, when I ran
that piece of code
through the open source
closure compiler,
you can see the same functional
piece of code at the bottom.
It's much, much more terse.
It fits on a single line,
and you can even see
that it's taken away some
of those extraneous function
calls that I've made,
and it's really--
I don't think you could write
that any more succinctly.
So why would you
run your code
through a compiler
or a minifier?
Well, the obvious answer
is that it's smaller,
as you just saw.
Many lines of code
with large variable names,
it became very small.
So this really helps
in the download component,
so the files themselves
are much smaller.
The second advantage,
and this really applies more
to the compiler
than to the minifier,
is that it can make
your code itself simpler.
It can, if you've got
a mathematical expression,
it might be able to
pre-calculate that
at compilation time, and it can
in-line functions away.
So the code itself
can become simpler,
which can speed up the pausing
and the execution on the page.
And I think one of the most
important reasons
that you'd want
to use a compiler
is that it actually can make
your JavaScript maintainable.
Because you're not worried
about the code
you're actually writing is going
to be sent to the end user,
you can be very,
very clear in your code.
You can write
large comments.
You can use very descriptive
variable names,
and you don't have to worry
about all those little
extra bytes that are being sent
down to the client every time.
The closure compiler also has
another really powerful tool
which helps keep
your JavaScript maintainable,
and that's that it provides
typing to JavaScript.
So you can do things
like define object types,
define interfaces,
and the compiler can catch
little errors you're making
like typos or wrong
number of arguments
to a function call
at the compilation time,
so you get your answers
straight away,
rather than after 20 minutes
of digging through stack traces.
The open source closure compiler
actually forms the basis
of how we, as the API team,
compile all our code,
and there is an externs file
available in the SVN repository
which lets you compile
your own web application
against our API.
Just to give you a little
feeling for how powerful
these minifiers
and compilers are,
here are two
real world examples.
The JQuery library,
when you concatenate
just the raw source files,
is about 233 KB.
After minification,
that drops down to 94 KB.
The Maps API itself weighs
in at a massive 2.4 MB
before we do
any compilation of it.
And you think that's
an amazing amount of code,
but that also includes
a lot of commenting,
a lot of documentation that we
have in our code directly there,
because it makes it much more
easy for us to work with it.
After we've run it
through a compiler,
the whole API is reduced
down to 336 KB.
That's in the order of 14%
of the original size.
Raub: So though it's important
to make each of your files
as small as possible,
it's also important to remember
that each file counts
when you download it.
This is a waterfall chart
from Firefox 3.0,
where we're loading 13
different JavaScript files
with a total of 730 KB of data,
and this took 4.5 seconds.
Each of these is downloaded
in sequence.
Now, many browsers
since Firefox 3.0
can actually load files
in parallel,
and this becomes much shorter
time and much better,
but we're still dealing with
many old browsers out there
and many mobile devices
that have low CPU, low RAM,
and low bandwidth often,
and so the load time
can't be as paralyzed
for these reasons.
And so if we take those files
and instead bundle them
into two separate downloads,
where we're still loading
that same 730 KB,
we can get the time
down to 1.8 seconds
to load that same
amount of data.
So where possible, use multiple
files for development,
but then make sure
to concatenate them
before you serve them
to your users
so that those resources
load quicker.
These same principles
apply to images.
So with images,
we can concatenate images
by using what we call
an image sprite.
An image sprite is a collection
of multiple individual images
in one larger image
that's loaded together,
but then only
shown in portions.
So here we have,
at the top,
we see three different
Pegman images.
But there's actually--
to show Pegman,
because we show him
at so many different angles
as you drag him
around the map--
there are actually
about 30 Pegmans.
But they're all concatenated
into one image
because usually we need all of
these 30 Pegmans all together.
So we load that one image,
and then using HTML and CSS
can show only the relevant
Pegman.
So here are some code snippets
for doing it purely in HTML
and then another to show
a CSS block for it.
So when doing it in HTML,
you specify a div
that is the width
and height of the image
you actually want to show--
so the actual,
the size of the actual Pegman.
You set its overflow
to be hidden
so that anything
extending outside of that div
is not shown.
Then you put inside
the div an image tag,
which the source
is the complete image sprite--
so the full 30 Pegmans.
Then offset
within that image,
you set the left
and top positions
so to be the point in the image
where that Pegman starts,
the top left corner
of that Pegman.
So because this particular
Pegman that I'm showing
on the slide is 98 pixels
into the image,
I set the left position
to be -98 pixels.
The CSS is very similar,
except that you can use
the background image property
and the background position.
Now, the downfall
of using the div
is it's harder to print images
that are in divs
with background images.
It depends on the browser,
whether you can do that;
otherwise, it's a great way
to go for rendering
your image sprites.
Day: So another way you can
bundle your images together
is to bundle them directly
into the HTML itself
rather than alongside
other images.
On this slide,
I've got two blue markers,
but the way that those two
markers are being rendered
by the browser, the way
they've been delivered
to the browser
is completely different.
The top one is very much
the traditional image
that you probably
all know and love.
It's just an image tag
which specifies
where its source is.
So when the browser
encounters this tag,
it needs to make a HTTP request
to your server, go out,
request the image
from your server,
bring it back, download it,
decode it,
and then display it
on the page.
With the second marker,
I've actually included the data
for the marker directly
in the page itself,
so there's no extra connection
required.
To do this, we use something
known as data URLs,
and with a data URL,
you basically have to specify
four different things.
The first thing is that you
start the URL with data
instead of HTTP,
like you usually would.
The next thing you need to do
is tell the browser
what MIME type it's supposed
to be expecting,
so it knows how to decode
the data when it sees it.
And in this case,
it's an image ping.
The third thing you need to do
is tell the browser
how you're going to
encode the data for it,
and here we've down
Base64 encoding,
which is what you'll do
99.99% of the time.
And, lastly, you actually
include directly in the URL
the data of that image
encoded in Base64,
so the actual binary data
that describes that image.
Using the same data
URL techniques,
it's equivalent to embed
that image source directly
into a JavaScript file
or into a CSS file.
So wherever
it's most appropriate,
you can use it.
Now, why would you
want to use this,
and why would you
want to avoid it?
The obvious advantage,
as I already discussed,
is that there's one less
HTTP connection.
So if you have a page
with a small icon,
the browser doesn't need to do
any extra network work
to get that image
on the page for you.
And also it can be conceptually
simpler than spriting.
Because each image
contains the data
for a single part of your image,
you don't have to worry about
where your little image fits
in the context
of the much larger sprite
and be worrying about offsets.
You can deal with
one image at a time.
On the other hand,
there is limited support
for data URLs
in older browsers.
For example, Internet Explorer 7
has no support at all,
and IE 8 has limited support.
On the other hand,
to this point,
all modern mobile browsers
do support data URLs,
so they're a really good
candidate for data URLs,
because in these devices, you do
have really limited bandwidth.
For example, in the Maps API,
we actually use data URLs
to deliver all the images
required for our zoom controls,
for example,
in mobile devices.
The other thing that's worth
bearing in mind
is that that Base64 encoding
of the binary data
can swell the image
by about 1/3.
Generally, if your server is set
up to handle GZipping correctly,
though, that overhead pretty
much shrinks to nothing.
And just briefly,
just to show you
that it's not a very difficult
task to actually generate
that Base64 data,
on the top code snippet,
I've got three lines of Python
which open up any image file,
or any file, really,
and return what
that Base64 data looks like.
The bottom line is actually
a little bit more advanced,
I guess, in that it's a PHP
script which will generate
the Base64 encoding at runtime
in the server.
So you don't even
have to worry about storing
that Base64 data anywhere.
Now, the principles
we've talked about for images
apply just as strongly
to JavaScript and CSS
and really any resource
that you can use it with.
So with JavaScript,
as Susannah mentioned,
keep those files together.
If you can use a compiler
to compile
all these source codes together,
that's fantastic.
And, also, only load
the bare essentials
into the head tag itself,
because anything
in that head tag
can stop the body
from rendering properly
until all your script is
downloaded, parsed, and run.
So if you've got
heavy white things, like--
things that deal with,
especially user interaction,
try and load those later on
in the page's lifetime.
It's also useful to try
and keep common scripts
from infrequently used scripts.
So if you use some parts
of your library
on every single page
of your site,
keep them in a separate file
to those that you're using
only on one or two pages
because, that way, the user
is always going to have
that common page
in their cache
and they won't have to
re-download it
for every page they visit.
Again, apply the--these concepts
to CSS as well.
Bundle the fast together,
compile them, minify them
if you can, and also,
at all costs,
avoid the @import tag,
because what that means is
the browser has to go out,
read one CSS file
from your server,
and only then does it know
that it needs to go
and start downloading
a second one.
So it can really
significantly delay
how long it takes to start.
Raub: Now, in developing
the Maps API,
we use all of the techniques
that we've talked about so far:
delay loading code,
compiling and minification,
image spriting,
embedding data URLs,
and concatenating JavaScript
to have fewer downloads.
To walk you through exactly
how the Maps API loads this,
you, the developer, start here
in the upper left hand corner
by loading the Maps API
bootstrap, as we call it--
so embedding the script tag
on your page.
This then loads a file
that is the bare minimum
it takes you to load,
to start developing
your mapping application.
So we load only the interfaces
and what we call main.js.
This is all the classes
that you can instantiate.
You, the developer,
then create a new map,
giving it the center
of the zoom, its map type ID,
at which point
we do actually have
a little bit of implementation
in that first code
just to make this part faster,
just to load a static map
right away.
At the same time,
we go and we delay load, the--
all of the implementation
for the actual functionality
of the map.
But here, when we have to
load multiple files,
we'll concatenate them.
At that point,
we then load the map tiles.
So we're loading things
as you need them,
both compiled together
as small as possible
but split out
where appropriate.
Now, I'd like to talk
a little bit more
to drive home this point
of how we do things,
about the new Maps API
Libraries feature.
So over time, that interface
file, that main.js,
can grow and grow, as we add
more and more features.
So to get around adding
these features to all developers
who might not need these new
really specialized features,
and all you want to do
is show a map with a marker
and don't want all of our
fancy new features.
So we've added
these libraries.
So when you request
the bootstrap,
you ask for the particular
libraries that you want.
So in this example,
the AdSense library,
which has a component
called the ad unit
which can render ads
on your map.
When this loads, that file--
that AdSense module
or that AdSense library--
is then concatenated
with the main interface library,
main.js.
It then extends the google.maps
name space to include
adsense.AdUnit.
So it's all still
part of the same download,
the same library,
but we have not created
a single additional download,
and any developer who's not
using this feature
does not have
any extra bytes added.
I'm going to switch gears now
a little bit and talk about,
start talking about how
you can use servers,
both yours and ours and those
around the world to help you.
And we're going to talk
about caching here.
So as just a little background
to caching here,
if a user is sitting in front
of a web browser
and asks for
a particular website,
and it's not in a cache
anywhere,
it will go all the way up
to the original server
to fetch the resources--
say, maps.google.com,
our cloud up at the top
of the image.
But subsequent requests,
if the cache headers
are set correctly,
can be served
by the browser cache,
making the request
almost instantaneous.
That original request
can take a long time
if that server is far away,
or slow, or lots of hops
between the user
and that server.
But if--there are all
these intermediary caches
between the browser
and that end server.
And so if a user is,
say, sitting next door,
who's on the same ISP
as our first user,
loads that same page,
when that user goes
to request the page,
it will go, say,
to the ISP cache
because these people
are on the same ISP,
and most ISPs will have
a cache sitting there
that can serve these resources.
And subsequent requests
will also go to their own
browser cache.
Now, a third person,
who also maybe lives nearby--
let's say these people
are all in Australia.
We're loading things
across the Pacific Ocean.
It can be really slow,
and it's great
when things are hosted
inside of Australia.
This third user,
also in Australia
but on a different ISP,
when they request this page,
they hit a content
distribution network,
something like Akamai,
where these pages are--
these resources are cached
within that resource.
So that's within that server.
So that's in Australia,
instead of having to go all
the way back up to the server.
So by setting cache headers
correctly,
all users can benefit,
not just the one who's loaded
the page already.
But you have to be aware.
Say I have--I collect photos
of my favorite animal.
And my favorite animal
is a cow.
And I'm going to use this cow
to illustrate a point
of having multiple resources
on a page that need to be
kept in sync.
So I'm going to take my cow,
and I'm actually going to
split him into two.
And I'm going to call my photo
animal left and animal right
because this is a page
dedicated to my favorite animal
at the time.
So I've got my cow,
and I've split him in half,
into two parts.
Now, I probably wouldn't
actually split my cow image
in half.
I'm just showing you
synchronized resources here.
So it's important that
the left half of the animal
and the right half of
the animal are always the cow.
But then I take this trip
to Nepal,
and I see
this really cool yak,
and the yak is now
my favorite animal.
So I've decided to take my page
and just change the file,
the animal left
and animal right file,
in order to show the yak now.
But say that when my user
sits down,
they go to load animal left
and animal right,
and because you can only control
how long a cache is allowed
to keep something
in its cache,
you cannot control when it--
that it will keep it there.
The cache is allowed to evict
anything from it
whenever it wants.
So when the user goes to load
the favorite animal page,
when they load animal left,
it's hit the cache,
and the cow
is still in cache.
So animal left is the cow,
but animal right
has been evicted from the cache,
and so the user's request
goes all the way back up
to the end server,
and they get a yak.
So now they see half a yak
and half a cow--not so good.
So when you want to keep
multiple resources in sync,
it's important to use
some sort of versioning.
So here, if I just--
instead of overriding
the animal left
and animal right files,
I'd rename them to yak left
and yak right.
Then, when the page loads,
when that HTML page loads
that has these embedded,
it will--
you have to change that page
to say yak left
and yak right.
And then if that page
was in cache,
the cow will still
be fetched.
If the page was not in cache,
the yak will be fetched,
and we never get
the yak-cow problem.
So a good general rule
for how to set cache headers,
which are set on the server--
so either your Apache server,
your App Engine,
whatever your server is--
a good general rule is things
like HTML don't cache them
or set their cache expiry
to be however long of latency
you want your pages
to upload or to refresh.
So if it's okay for users to
see data an hour that's stale,
let them be cached
for an hour.
But generally
don't cache HTML.
Do cache forever JavaScript
Images, CSS, all of that,
and then use versioning
within your HTML
to fetch the new resource,
and always get it
from the server when
you want it to be refreshed.
And so you set the cache
control headers to public,
and with an expiry date
really far in the future.
Now, I mentioned
that the proximity of servers
makes a big difference
to the users.
One way to help move things
closer to your users
may be to use a content
distribution network
such as the Google
Libraries API.
The Google Libraries API
makes some common
JavaScript libraries available
on Google servers,
which are often going to be
closer to your user
than your server,
just because Google has servers
all over the world.
So here in this image, we see
that the user is the red star.
And instead of having to go all
the way to the yellow pentagon,
which is your server,
it only has to go to
Google's server,
which is just a little hop
across that channel of water.
Day: All right,
so now we've talked
about some of the techniques
to get the page
and everything on your page,
loading quickly.
We now sort of want to change
pace a bit and talk about
how to make the page itself,
once it's in the browser,
seem performant.
So I'm going to start with
a little bit of a walk
down memory lane.
In the beginning, back in 2005,
maps.google.com was born.
And with it came what I think
is a pretty attractive marker
the designers came up with
to really show locations
on a map where restaurants are,
where pizza is,
more importantly, to make it
really stand out on the map,
make it feel like it was
actually standing on the map
instead of part of it.
They introduced the drop shadow,
which made it really, you know,
feel like it was standing up,
almost three-dimensional.
The problem was if a second
marker was placed close by,
that shadow from the first
marker would obscure it.
And you can see,
it just looks terrible.
So to get around that,
what we needed to do
was split the red marker image
from its shadow
into two separate images
so that we could
arrange them correctly,
and now we don't have
that problem.
Another problem
that we needed to solve
was how do you display more
information about that point,
when the user interacts with it?
So the info window was born.
An info window really takes that
curved 3D look of the marker
to the next level.
It really pops out of the page,
and it's got massive shadow
behind it
to make it feel like, you know,
a giant speech bubble
popping out of the earth.
The problem with that shadow is,
though,
it can obscure other things
like markers nearby.
And so you, as a user,
you can see that marker,
and you expect,
if I click that marker,
its info window is going to
open up instead.
But the browser has a completely
different interpretation
of what's going on.
It says that info window
and that shadow,
they're in front
of that marker,
and it only cares about what
order images or DOM elements
are arranged in the document.
And so when you click
the marker,
it thinks you're actually
clicking the shadow.
To get around this, we actually
had to add a third image--
I mean, a third DOM element
onto the page,
and that was just something
the user couldn't see,
an invisible element
in front of the marker,
so that when the user
did click it,
that invisible element
caught the click
and was able to redirect it
appropriately.
All of that actually can lead
to some performance issues.
So on this map,
I'm going to draw
approximately 1,200 markers
which represent the location
of Canadian airports.
Susannah,
will you do the honors?
Raub:
Yes.
One Mississippi,
two Mississippi,
three Mississippi, four.
Day: Maybe 3 1/2
Mississippis?
So it takes a long time
to render those on the map.
But what's worse is,
even when they're on there,
the performance
is pretty terrible.
You can see
it's laggy when I zoom.
It just feels messy.
It feels like
I'm not interacting
with the map anymore.
It's just a cludgy experience.
So as an API team, we really
had to solve this problem,
and there were two ways
we really could do it.
One was to simplify,
to get rid of this marker,
which we've all
come to know and love--
try and simplify it, maybe
make it smaller and boxier,
get rid of shadows,
so we didn't have
any of these clicking problems,
maybe simplify
the info window again,
make it smaller and boxier,
and then use just
normal DOM rendering.
All we had to work out,
how do we solve this problem
while keeping the aesthetics?
And the lesson we came to--
well, what we learned
was the DOM is slow.
Every time your JavaScript
reaches out
and talks to that page
and tries to make it
do something,
add an extra element,
you are incurring a real cost.
So that's why we were really
excited when canvas
came on the scene.
Now, for those of you who
aren't familiar with canvas,
it's considered one of
the HTML5 technologies.
You basically can think
of canvas
as your favorite
paint program.
It's just a dumb pixel buffer
that sits on the page.
You can draw points on it.
You can draw lines and circles.
You can write text into it.
You can even draw
other images into it.
But once you've drawn
those things,
the canvas doesn't care about
the content anymore.
It just worries about the
pixels, so what it looks like.
Just to give you an idea of how
quickly canvas performs
compared to images, I'm going
to draw 10,000 images here
on the left.
You see, it's not quite
3 1/2 Mississippis here,
but it's still,
seemed like noticeably slow.
You can see the delay.
If I do the same operation
in canvas,
by the time I finish clicking,
the markers have all been drawn.
Now, I'm just going to throw up
a couple of code snippets,
and these are just to give you
an idea of what's involved
in using canvas.
It's probably not something
that you're going to use
in every element
of your page.
It's really something
where you're worried
about performance.
But here's what the code
would look like--
well, did look like--
in that left hand side,
where I was using
image elements.
It basically consists
of two things.
One is creating a DOM element,
which is the image,
and setting its source
and its position
so that it's in the right place
on the page and looks right,
and then adding that to
a parent node,
so that it's actually
added to the document.
The equivalent piece of code
for canvas
has a couple of extra
complications.
One is, once we've got
the canvas download,
we actually have to ask
the canvas
for its drawing context.
You can think of that
as that DOM pixel buffer.
The other thing we have to do
is load the image onto the page
and wait for the image
to have arrived
before we try and draw
into the canvas.
As I mentioned earlier, well,
I've mentioned a few times now,
the canvas is just
a pixel buffer.
So if you try and draw an image
that hasn't even arrived
on the page yet, it's not
going to know what to do,
and it's going to just
ignore it for you.
Nothing is going to happen.
So you do have to have
that complication of waiting
for an image to load
before you can draw it.
But you can see it's actually
not significantly more code,
just a little bit
of a mind shift.
So when we applied this and
a few other little techniques
we had up our sleeves
to markers,
you can see what difference
it made.
Susannah?
Raub: Okay.
One Mississ--
Day: Oh.
It's less than
a Mississippi.
It's probably a small creek
somewhere.
But now, as well as drawing
quickly, look how that feels.
It's panning smoothly.
It's zooming smoothly.
It actually feels like,
once again,
I'm in the page
with the map.
There's nothing between me
and the map,
and we're interacting
directly.
Raub: One thing that should
be noted, too,
is this is actually a very
fast machine that we're on here,
and if you were on a slower
machine, a smaller one,
anything, that 3 1/2
Mississippis could be
a lot more than that,
and dragging would be
absolutely impossible.
Now, there's another part to how
we made the markers
as fast as we did with canvas,
and I need to back up
a little bit to talk about
and explain how we did this.
So one of the initial features
that set Google Maps apart
from its predecessors,
originally, back in 2004-2005,
was that it was
infinitely draggable.
Previously, Maps had been loaded
with one static image
that had to change
each time you wanted to pan
to a new part of the map
and load a fresh image.
This is partly because showing
at zoom level ten,
which is half of the zoom levels
that we have on Google Maps,
would take about
15 gigabytes of data
to render that whole map
of the world.
So if you wanted a draggable
map for the whole world
at zoom level ten,
your browser would have
been able to do that.
Now, we've seen that the browser
can't even handle
10,000 small marker elements.
I'm sure 10,000 elements
is different than one big one,
but really
it can't do either.
So Google Maps,
what it originally did
was take that world imagery
and cut it, pre-compute,
cut it into slices,
256 X 256 pixel images
that could then
be sent to the client
and stitched together there,
which then when dragged,
would load
as they're necessary
and create
this infinite dragging.
So here we see
in the center,
that's the map
that the user actually sees,
and what's behind it
is what we're not loading.
Often, we load
a padding around it,
but what's behind there would be
what you would have to load
in order to have the same
functionality without tiles.
So we apply this technique
to a number of different things
that we do on the map,
one of those being
those canvas markers.
And so instead of just
rendering all of the markers
in the canvas
all the time
and having to have one
that's as big as the map,
we split it into these tiles
and render them in parts.
So when looking at
the Canadian airports,
if you're zoomed in
on British Columbia,
we will not show, we will not
render the canvas markers
for all of the airports
in Nova Scotia, as well.
We will only be rendering
those for British Columbia,
doing as little work
as possible.
Now, an alternative to using
canvas markers
and doing that all on the client
is KML.
KML is an open source format
for representing geographic data
and presenting
geographic data.
It's an XML format that allows
you to specify place marks,
extended information
about place marks,
polylines, polygons,
ground overlays,
and other things to render
on the map.
Now, we have in the Maps API
a KML layer,
and when you specify a KML file
to that KML layer,
it sends a request
to our server,
which goes out and fetches
your KML file,
so it must be hosted
on a publicly available server.
It fetches that KML file,
comes back to the server,
renders all of that,
parses that file
and renders it all
into image tiles
that are then requested
by the client.
So each of these KML files
are split into tiles
just like our marker rendering
for the canvas
and just like our image tiles
for actually showing the map.
This means that you can show
10,000 or so place marks
in exactly the same amount
of time as one.
There is no added cost
to showing more place marks
when loading it from KML.
But KML, as I said,
is this XML format,
and each time you want
to change the data,
you have to
regenerate the file.
So if you're trying
to add more data,
you have to regenerate
the file, re-upload it,
and, of course,
version it because of caching.
So an alternative of this
is to use Fusion Tables.
Fusion Tables is Google's
online data store for any data,
but it's particularly good
for location-based data.
Fusion Tables allows you
to store in rows and columns
any sort of structured data,
and then, to be queried
by our Fusion Tables layer,
either as an entire table--
so here we see, again,
the Canadian airports loaded.
That's the entire table.
It's all 1,200 airports.
You can also specify a query
to only fetch part of the table.
This is an SQL-like query,
and here Dave is showing
if you specify, you ask
for only airports
with a minimum elevation.
And so dynamically
we have changed this table,
and at each level,
it has fetched new tiles
to show this airport data.
So just like KML,
just like our markers,
we render these things
into tiles
so that many points to render
take the same amount of time
as a few points to render.
Now, the other thing that both
KML and Fusion Tables do--
oh, and I should mention
there was a talk
on Fusion Tables yesterday,
so if you're interested
in learning more,
you should check out
Katherine and James' talk
online.
The other thing that KML
and Fusion Tables do
is they wait until a user needs
that extended data
before loading it
into the client.
So if you were to render
all those Canadian airports
by creating new markers
and having us render them,
though it may be fast
and draggable,
you would need to have data
at that time to
show what you want in,
say, the info window,
when you click on it.
But with KML and Fusion Tables,
when Dave clicks on that marker,
at that time, we go off
to the server
and request the extended data
for that airport in Nunavut,
and so no extra data
has been loaded into the client
until it's required.
Now, you can tile anything.
You can do this yourself.
At the time of the floods
in Brisbane in January,
we put together a map,
and we had this great overlay
that showed where the river
levels were predicted to go,
but this image
was quite large,
and loading it in
took some time.
And, again,
this is a fast machine,
so it didn't take
as long as it would have
on many other machines.
But dragging the map
became nearly impossible,
and this file is--
Dave, how big is this file?
Day:
Just over two megs.
Raub: Two megs, and so
that makes it almost impossible
for the browser to render,
and if we zoom in further,
it will become worse
and worse.
So instead,
we need to create tiles.
Now, the image map type class
in the Maps API
makes it very easy
to load tiles.
You can use open source tools,
such as Map Tiler
and a few others
to cut your large image
into individual tiles.
What this does is,
at each zoom level,
creates tiles that specify
for each coordinate
in whatever size images
you're telling it.
So we often use
256 X 256 pixels.
It works pretty well.
So after cutting
the large image
into these individual tiles,
the image map type defines
the get tile URL function,
which just returns a URL
to the image that you want.
And so for our format,
it's the path
where all the tiles are
and then they're stored
in one directory
for the zoom level
and then in each zoom level,
one directory for each
X coordinate
and then each
Y coordinate.
You can have your format be
whatever you want for these,
but all you need to do
in the image map type
is return the URL for the image,
for the coordinate
and zoom level that we've
passed in to get tile URL.
So the result of that,
it loads a lot faster.
It zoomed--or it pans,
it zooms,
and we get the added benefit
that image map type
supports opacity,
so we no longer have an opaque
blue overlay on the map.
We now have this semitransparent
blue,
and you can still see
where the towns are
that were to be flooded.
You can tile anything,
not just images.
The map type interface
in the API gives you
a coordinate,
and you create a div,
and you return the div
instead of a URL.
So here I've created
this coordinate map type,
which--so for each coordinate
and zoom level,
it just prints out
the coordinates,
which could be useful
maybe to use,
while developing
your other tiled map types.
So the map type interface
just requires you
to specify a tile size
and to define get tile.
And so get tile passes
in the coordinate,
the zoom level,
and the document.
We pass in the document,
so that we don't have
any problems with i-frames,
so that you're creating
the element
with the correct document.
So you take our document.
You call create element on it,
make it a div.
I guess you could give it
any node.
We'll attach any DOM element
to the DOM for you,
and then you can put whatever
you want in it,
and we will position it
on the correct tile,
because the world is split
into these fixed boundaries,
where at zoom level zero,
there's one tile,
and so the coordinate
is always 00.
It's then at zoom level one,
divided into quadrants,
and then at each tile
from there,
it's divided again
into four.
Day: So the other approach
you can take
is simplifying the data before
you give it to the browser,
because, as we saw,
everything you can give
to the browser
incurs a cost.
If you saw Jazz and Luke's talk
on User Experience yesterday,
then you also realize
that often bombarding your users
with information
can overwhelm them.
It's the same
with the browser.
So the principle
you should always apply
is keep it simple,
Susannah.
[laughter]
Thank you.
I practiced that one earlier.
[laughter]
Here, you can see we're using
the open source market cluster
to again use those 1,200
Canadian airports on the map.
But instead of rendering
1,200 markets,
we're rendering
relatively few,
which just gives you an overview
of where those airports are.
So here, the heavy lifting
was done by the JavaScript
before we started talking
to the DOM,
and doing things
in pure JavaScript
is generally really quick.
Now, things like JavaScript
in canvas as we saw,
can really start to take away
that heavy lifting
from the browser,
but a new technology,
which takes it one step further,
and actually asks
your users' graphics card
to take away the heavy lifting
is WebGL.
WebGL is based on
the OpenGL ES Library,
which is the same graphics
libraries used
by all mobile devices to render
graphics in 3D context.
So it is like a powerful
open standard
to get 3D graphics
performance.
To give you an example of
how powerful this can be,
I've got two panoramas,
street view panoramas here,
which I've rendered
in two different ways.
On the left hand side,
I've rendered using just
traditional canvas 2D,
and we've carved up
the street view triangles
to make it actually fit
together right,
so you get
the right perspective.
And you can see, as I pan,
it's a bit jumpy,
it's a bit jarry.
It's not terrible,
but, again, it's not great.
And actually,
we had this performance,
this same demo running
on my Mac,
and it was absolutely unusable.
You'd get a refresh maybe
once every second or so.
It was--you couldn't
use this at all.
So if you do, check out
our slides later online.
Try it out
on your own machine,
and see how canvas
is performing for you.
On the right,
we've got the same imagery,
but this time using WebGL,
so we're using
the graphics card,
and you can see
it's absolutely smooth.
It's absolutely crisp,
and that's because
now the browser
is not doing the work.
It's the graphics card.
And this is sort of
the exciting future
that we're getting
towards in browsers,
where we can rely on these tools
more and more to actually do
some of this heavy lifting
and get a much more compelling
experience for our users.
All right, so...
to get started,
here's some great resources.
I recommend you go
and check out all three.
The top one is really how
do you get your website
and your server working well,
and the compiler is about
that JavaScript compiler
I talked about earlier.
And then, of course,
I really encourage you
to go and check out
all our API documentation,
which includes a lot of
guides, articles,
and example code, as well.
So thank you all
for your time,
and we'd love to answer
any questions you've got,
if you want to stand up
to the mic.
Raub: Thank you.
[applause]
man:
Hello, I've got two questions,
if that's okay.
Day: Sure.
man: The first one is when
you're rendering the KML tiles,
and you're rendering things
from Fusion Tables,
how much do you depend
on the pure raw power
of the cloud to dynamically
render those tiles,
and how much do you render
that kind of ahead of time?
So if a user uploads data
to fusion tiles--
or to the Fusion Tables--
do you try and do
a couple of zoom levels?
Because there's 23, you don't
want to try and do everything.
Day: Actually, usually,
we rely on the pure raw power,
especially with Fusion Tables,
where we don't know what query
and what, you know, even what
the data might be in the table,
until you ask for the tile.
So you really have to do
all of that rendering
right there and then.
We do some smart things,
like try to index it,
but it's mostly just power.
man: Okay.
Raub: It's also--it has to make
a round-trip to the server
to actually fetch the tile,
which is probably
so much greater
than the amount of time
we're spending on the server,
that it's so greatly outweighed
by the network time.
man: Okay.
And the other quick question
I had was
a lot of this is great,
but there's a lot of customers--
larger enterprise
or disconnected networks--
that may want to use this
or don't want to be uploading
their data to public
Google servers.
Is there any way that this will
be integrated back with, like,
the Google Earth
Enterprise Team,
bring some of this capability
back that way,
especially the KML rendering.
Day: I'm not sure of any plans
on those regards.
Definitely, all the stuff
we talked earlier,
like the canvas,
you can use that
without ever that data
coming to us.
And there is also,
there is a premier offering
for Fusion Tables.
You do store the data
in the cloud,
but it does help you keep it
much more private,
when it comes to
map rendering.
man: Okay.
Day: Yeah.
Raub: This is also
a great time to pitch.
At 12:45, I think it is,
we have the Geo Fireside Chat,
where we'll have a number
of our product managers,
who would be even better
to answer such questions.
man:
Okay, thank you.
Regarding the using canvas
for drawing the markers,
does it fall back
to the old style
of rendering them
if the browser
doesn't support it?
Day: Yeah, we definitely,
we fall back
whenever the browser
is not going to--
whenever the browser is going
to use the old way better.
And also for things
like draggable markers,
it's more complicated
to do that in canvas
than it is to have
a DOM element there.
So there's a number of reasons
we fall back when we need to.
man:
Okay, thank you.
Raub: We also,
we used VML for IE,
but it turned out VML
wasn't actually doing
the same techniques
as canvas.
Doing it in VML wasn't
actually such a win,
so we're still rendering
DOM elements there,
but doing some other
sort of trickery
to get it to be
as fast as possible.
So it's important to look at--
what you can do in canvas,
you can normally do in VML,
but it's important to figure out
are you actually winning
from doing it in VML?
man: Yeah, maybe on that,
can you elaborate which browsers
might not support canvas
or VML, if you know?
Raub: Right.
So canvas is supported
in all WebKit browsers.
Day:
All Mozilla.
Raub:
Yeah.
Day:
And IE 9, I think.
Is that right?
Raub: Yeah, I think so.
Day:
Yeah.
Raub: And we've found it to be
faster on all of those browsers.
man: Any news on supporting
vector type of drawing,
such as a SVG type of drawing,
instead of just
a raster caching?
Day: It's a really
exciting problem.
We don't actually have
any concrete plans,
mostly because still, like,
as we saw with WebGL,
like, it's the browsers
that are catching up.
Like, we could probably do
that all in native client,
as you see in the Maps
client on Android,
but then doing it
in the browsers--
they're just one step behind.
man: All right. Thank you.
Raub:
And you mentioned SVG.
It's a good time to mention
Android doesn't
actually support SVG.
So if you're doing
something in SVG,
make sure you have a canvas
implementation, as well.
man:
Thanks.
man: When you use the canvas
to draw the markers,
you can't attach the click
handler directly to the marker.
Day:
Right.
man: So there's magic
done by Google Maps
in the background to figure out
where it actually goes?
Raub: Yes.
Day: Yeah, exactly.
And we find that's not slow.
Because you're only
clicking very rarely,
you can spend a few tens
of milliseconds,
then, going back and working out
which point corresponds
to which marker,
and the user doesn't notice.
man: But that just all happens
locally in JavaScript, right?
Day: Yeah,
that's right, yeah.
Raub: Something, though,
in canvas,
any time that a resource is
loaded cross domain,
you can't access that pixel data
any longer.
So one way to hit detection
with canvas
is to inspect the pixel data
of the canvas
and see whether there's
something there or not.
But if you've loaded
your image cross domain,
you can no longer do that
for security reasons.
So you need to have
another way.
And so this is a problem
we faced,
because all of our--the API is
always loaded on your domains
and refreshing images
from our domain,
and so we can't use
that sort of hit detection.
We have to actually keep track
of where everything is
that we've drawn,
if that makes sense.
man: Any suggestions about
improving performance
of multiple polygons in a map
with a large number of polygons?
Raub: So we certainly have
spent a lot of time
making a lot of
small polygons fast
and few big polygons fast.
I think there were
some recent improvements
in the last month
for polygons.
So if you have a site--I would
say the best thing to do,
if you have a site
where you think your polygons
are just too slow,
send it to us.
Day: And try the most current
version first,
because we have made a lot
of improvements recently.
Raub: Yeah,
but that's something--
one of the guys on our team
is really into getting polygons
to be fast.
So if you send him a demo that
shows that they're not fast,
chances are he'll spend
next weekend improving it.
man: And how do we send it
to you?
Raub: The best thing to do is
actually probably send it--
post it on the group.
man: Okay.
Raub: Because other people
might be interested
in seeing that as well.
man: Thank you.
Raub: So do we need to tell you
where our group is?
Search for Google Groups
Maps API V3--
Day: If you go
to the documentation,
it'll show a link
for there.
man: Hi, you showed clustering
a few slides ago.
Day:
Yep.
man:
Is there any clustering done
or can be done natively
on mobiles?
Day: That clustering
was all done in JavaScript.
man: Yeah, that was Fluster,
wasn't it?
Day: No, it was the open
source V3 marker clusterer.
man: Okay.
Day: Which is linked to
from our documentation
and the groups,
and it's all done--
instead of giving
the marker to the map
or the map to the marker
like you usually would,
you instead
create the marker
and give it to the clusterer,
and then it worries
about putting them together
and forming those clusters
all natively on the client.
man: And does that handle
custom markers, as well?
Day:
Yeah, custom.
Raub: That was
a custom marker.
Day: That had
custom markers.
Raub: That little blue guy
was a custom marker,
so you just pass--you create
markers the same way you would
any time, so you pass it
a full marker options object,
and then the one thing you
don't do is set the map on it,
and you give it
to the marker cluster,
and it will render them.
man: For an Android
or an iPhone app,
is it recommended
to use a web view
and then render the map inside
the web view with a V3 API,
or is it better
to use a native?
Raub: So I'd say we're
partial to the browser,
since that's what
we work on.
But I'd say that the real
benefits of using the browser
are that it's cross platform,
you write it once
for iPhone and Android,
and we actually also work
on BlackBerry and Bota,
so you get four mobile OS's
for one.
And then we have much
more active development
with a lot more features,
so you get a lot more.
man: Performance-wise,
they're getting very close,
native versus web view?
Raub:
We're still slower.
Day: For what it's worth--
correct me if I'm wrong--
but the map that you've got
in the I/O application
on your Android
uses web view.
man:
Okay.
Day: Just to give you a feel
of what the performance is like.
man: We have an app
in the market.
The second part of the question
was using street view DOMs
in our app, we tried to simulate
walking down the streets,
and we pick great routes
around the world,
and let people sample them.
So to simulate that, we load
panoramas, one after the other,
and using V3, we don't really
get that smooth nest
that we see in a Flash-based
or any other browser-based.
So are there any techniques
or trickery there
to try to make it like
a seamless walk down the street,
using street view?
Raub: It's certainly something
we would like to provide for you
in the future.
We would like our implementation
to be just like Flash.
It may or may not get there.
No promises as to when.
I don't know.
Day: I think there is
active interest in it,
in the Maps team,
generally.
So I think you will see
a lot of improvements coming.
man:
Okay, thank you.
Raub: Yeah, I can't think
of some great techniques
for you to do it
on your own locally.
man:
Okay, thanks.
man: Extending on the previous
question about the overlay
of the click handler,
there's a nice example.
You have a mouse pointer
which changes
when you move over a point.
If you have a canvas,
how do you do it
if you have, for example,
10,000 points?
Day: Again, we have to do it
all in JavaScript,
wherever we can, so we know
where the points are,
and we basically go
from this X coordinate.
Does that correlate
to one of the markers,
and should we change cursor?
man:
So with the tile,
you also send the data
to the client?
Day: Oh, yes,
for these ones, yeah.
We send a little bit of data,
just enough to let the browser
know what is clickable.
man:
Okay.
Day: But not the entire
information
about what each airport is,
for example.
man: Okay.
Day: Yeah.
man: Going along with
two questions ago,
regarding the web view with map
inside versus native app.
Day:
Yeah.
man: One thing that I really
feel to be a limitation today
is that the web view
doesn't pinch to zoom,
and people feel like they're
entitled to this functionality,
and it's not available
in web view.
Is this going to
come sometime?
Raub: So it's available
on the iPhone,
and it's available
in Android 3.0.
man:
Oh.
Raub: So if you try
your tablet,
it should work.
man: Cool, okay.
Raub: And that was a limitation
that was not exposed
in the browser by Android.
man: Okay.
Raub:
So it would have worked.
Our code works for it,
but Android didn't--
though it used pinch to zoom,
it did not expose
multitouch events.
Every touch event still only
had one touch in it.
man:
Great.
Raub:
But Android 3.0 fixes that.
And let us know if you have
problems with that,
because we don't
have the tablet,
so we haven't played with it
as much as you will.
[laughter]
Day: Hi.
man: Hi.
For your canvas example
and your Fusion Table example,
following the click event,
you create an info window,
which the information
is populated by--
it goes back to
the Google server.
That includes
the extra round-trip time.
I assume that's quick.
Day: Correct.
man: But I was just wondering
what's your thoughts on that?
Day: Yeah, it's sort of
weighing up the benefit
of how much does it cost
to get the page actually loaded
and functional versus
how much will the user wait?
A lot of the time
you can do tricky things,
like if you notice
the user hovering on it,
then start, because even if
they don't end up clicking,
you really haven't
wasted much.
And, yeah, I think, also,
when you do know you have to
go back to the server
and fetch something,
just let the user know
that something's happening,
because they'll get frustrated
and click it 17 times before--
you know--so it's sort of
a combination
of those two things,
trying to pre-guess
and also letting them know
what's happening.
Raub:
But that data is so simple,
that it's so small
that it's okay.
But if you knew
your user was--
or you knew you were going
to show these info windows,
then maybe don't load them
when you first load your page.
Do it in some timeout,
when you're done
rendering everything else,
and then fetch as many
as you can together.
man:
Okay.
Raub:
Would be my tip for that.
Day:
Last question?
man: For the Fusion Table
example, again,
with the click event,
if you had multiple markers
stacked on top of each other,
could you receive
all the information
from all the markers
with the click event?
Day: I think the implementation
at the moment
just supports
getting one event.
Raub: I mean, theoretically,
not with Fusion Tables,
but if you were to
implement this, you could.
You could pick
to have that feature,
but that's not how
we've done it.
man: Thank you.
Day: Okay.
Thanks, everyone.
And if you have
any more questions,
we'll be outside
afterwards.
Raub: And Fireside Chat
in an hour here.
[applause]